[Music]
let's get into this game battlefield I
have not played a first-person shooter
and a very long time so excuse me if I'm
not very good at it
now Sweden of course we shot a bunch of
kooks we didn't take part of the war
none of them but it's time for this
Swede to do it I'm gonna do it I'm gonna
kill people
okay well what the [ __ ] is this
skip am I gonna play with other people
hey I'm Turkey
hey I didn't I didn't know they did
anything how about that so Isis must be
over there thing right I already made an
isis joke this is a good start
alright here we go alright let's see if
we can see any enemies I see them
now I never - is fine I better not run
into any Germans oh it's those [ __ ]
Brits i [ __ ] they're bombing us oh [ __ ]
they got horses Jesus [ __ ] this man
well I need a medic all right I need a
[ __ ] medic thanks
I said medic not ammo Jesus all right
you go out and get him he's slowing
today how did he get me [ __ ] ash
they're shooting everywhere [ __ ] I hear
someone oh [ __ ] there he goes I can't
[ __ ] shoot everyone Jesus I'm so
[ __ ] bad at it if my dad saw my KD he
would disown me boom [ __ ] Oh shovel
that [ __ ] that's [ __ ] right
oh boy look who's on fight that
[ __ ] Sam in the ass Hey
stop that stop stop stop everyone just
stop come here I [ __ ] dare you
[Music]
[ __ ]
god damn shovels okay that could have
gone better I'm just warming up okay Oh
[Music]
God
throw something hey hey how the [ __ ] did
I survive that stop throwing nades oh
[ __ ] I blow myself up I panicked
hey I'm number one I was [ __ ]
beautiful
Schama
Chavo Chavo Chavo Chavo Chavo Chavo wow
I had a shovel
oh it's shoveling time shovel you that's
[ __ ] right you get the shovel you all
get the shovel [ __ ] I charge
I didn't [ __ ] danish people i swear
to god but honestly I'm just enjoying
playing the game it's really fun but I'm
pretty [ __ ] ok here we go alright I'm in
the game I'm in the forest I'm in the
jungle it's sweaty hey no that's my
[ __ ] flamethrower this is mine mine
mine mine
Hey look at that Layla hey it's the pot
of time y'all just cover me I'll burn
this [ __ ] place to the ground
that was [ __ ] awesome
hell yeah damn it
it's shoveling time baby that's [ __ ]
right I'm the king of the shovel don't
slam that's [ __ ] right shovel shovel
shovel that's [ __ ] right you're
shoveling son of a [ __ ] [ __ ] damn it oh
I'm pissed now now I am [ __ ] pissed
[Applause]
this is playing shut up
gotcha [ __ ] Oh Snoop Doggy down
[ __ ] I am vegan buddy
vegan shop oh great
I'm the German Empire now that is good
Dutch make me happy did he just [ __ ]
run for it
shovel doctor stash German Way shovel
that's [ __ ] right Jesus Christ he
flew everywhere look at this guy
I did that alright good look at this
[ __ ]
hey buddy sprang a night about up I
didn't kill him are you serious
are you [ __ ] kidding me splat I
didn't brush I've never been this pissed
9 my [ __ ] shovel thanks - shovel and
touch me
wait what's shovel in German Shravan
[Music]
well well huh that was battlefield ah
it's really fun game I really enjoy it
check out the game
leave a like be enjoyed and I'm gonna
keep playing better have a good one
[Music]